[Music]
girls are just as good as boys in
anything we know how to hit we know how
to run and we can definitely play
football so when I heard boys chanting
beat that girl hate that girl all made
me want to do was beat them even better
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm Sam Gordon I'm 14 years old and I
started the first female tackle football
league I've been playing with the boys
since I was nine years old
in my very first season I scored 35
touchdowns about like 1,900 yards
sometimes after I'd beat him the parents
would come out onto the field to grab
their sons case and be like don't let a
girl beat you I wanted to start the
girls tackle football league after
talking at a school assembly and asking
the question how many girls here would
want to play tackle football almost
every hand in the room went up so I got
the idea like okay if there's this many
at this one school imagine how many
there are in Utah or just in the nation
so I talked to my dad and we talked with
some other people after a while we had
the first season of the Utah girls
tackle football league up and running
football is the last frontier in girl
sports and if you think about it girls
can play on girls teams in every sport
that you can think of except for the
country's most popular sport we limited
participation to 50 girls those spots
filled up in less than a week the
following year we had 100 girls and then
this season we've had over 200 girls who
are playing every year we keep getting
bigger and bigger and bigger would be
amazing for it to go into high schools
colleges and even its own professional
league and that's gonna be a tough goal
to reach about I am really ambitious and
I feel like we could do it with the
girls you could tell that everybody
really wants to be there and so
everybody it's just super into it and
always willing to learn with the girls
every practice is just an awesome time
[Music]
you